hey youtubers is Charlie so today we're
gonna talk about gorilla grodd because
andrew kriesberg one of the executive
producers on the flash show tweeted this
message in honor of Geoff Johns birthday
last week it almost went unnoticed
because he doesn't have a lot of
followers but it's a really big deal if
you've never had the chance to meet
Geoff Johns he's just one of the most
famous flash comics writers and he's
very involved in the TV show whenever
he's not off writing other comic books
or advising on the DC movies
he's like chief creative at DC so he
does like everything that they do movies
TV shows comics this video is mostly
gonna be a history of Grodd in the
comics but I will talk about how I think
the show is gonna use him if you've
never read the comics or you've never
seen any of the animated DC shows most
people see korilla Grodd and they think
he's like the Ceasar of the DC Universe
like a super smart gorilla who ushered
in a new age for gorilla kind in reality
he's more like Koba so levar is more
like Caesar
don't worry I'll explain who so levar is
it's just like when you start talking
about Grodd there's a lot of Grodd
specific characters that you have to
talk about also and so levar it's the
biggest one they're like the yin and the
yang of gorilla society in the DC
Universe so rewind to last year we all
saw the flash pilot there was a Gorilla
Grodd Easter egg at the end but we
really didn't know what it meant and it
seemed like it was just meant to be an
offhanded joke just like an inside joke
for comic book fans fast forward to now
so much has changed the show has become
so popular that Warner Brothers has
given the thumbs-up to bring him on the
show in a major story it just goes to
show you how plants can change over time
based on the popularity of stuff so if
the flash continues to be super popular
they will probably be able to do all
kinds of stuff we can't even think about
right now the character gorilla grodd
was created by carmine infantino he's a
really notable dc:creator I mean he's an
Marvel stuff too but he created most of
the Rogues and a whole bunch of other
minor DC Comics characters the first
time Grodd appeared in the comics was
flash number 106
in 1959 initially he was a normal girl
living in the African jungle with his
family until a radioactive meteorite
crashed nearby and imbued him with hyper
intelligence and telepathy it wasn't
just him either his comrade or his
fellow gorilla
solovar also got the same powers later
the retcon
turned the meteor into a crashed
radioactive ship and there was an alien
but before the retcon the meteor that
gave him his power
was also the same meteor that gave Green
Lantern villain Hector ham and his
powers I know there's always a lot of
crossover between Green Lantern stuff
and flash stuff every time we visit the
ferris airfield I always wonder if
they're gonna bring Carol Ferris on the
flash at some point I feel like she's
much more realistic than actually
bringing Hal Jordan on but fingers
crossed so just like Superman and all
the other DC characters the scope of
grodd's powers like his his superpowers
has changed over time just think of his
powers as being psionic based thus far
he's been able to take over other
people's minds create telekinetic force
beams transmute matter transfer his
consciousness into other bodies he has
super strength like way beyond that of
normal gorillas like gorillas are
already super strong but he's super
strong beyond that he's almost been able
to beat Kalibak the son of Darkseid just
just to give me an idea of the scope of
his strength physical strength in
slightly grosser he's shown that he's
been able to absorb intelligence by
eating other people's brains I'm gonna
go ahead and take a wild stab and say
the TV show probably not gonna show him
eating some red shirt scientists brain
it does that a lot of new context to
this new 52 cover though I always love
covers like this mmm flash brains so
tasty so gerado is mostly known as a
flash villain but inside gorilla society
so levar is his chief rival
they have the same kind of epic rivalry
that the flash and the reverse-flash
have Sullivan's usually presented as
being the nicer one Grodd as being the
crazier one that's why if if you saw the
Rise of the Planet of the Apes or any of
the Planet of the Apes films Caesar is
more like so levar
and Grodd is more like Koba one of the
earliest Grodd storylines explained how
he and so levar and the other gorillas
took the alien in the crash ship made in
their leader then they worked together
to create gorilla city that's like a
super advanced city of intelligent apes
hidden from the rest of the world if
you're a big fan of the Marvel Universe
it's a lot like the Inhumans where they
have a secret city that no one else
knows about
so eventually Explorer stumbled on
gorilla City Grodd forces one of them to
kill the alien leader then takes power
with the intention of using all the
gorillas to take over the world
so levar uses his telepathy to warn
Barry Allen who's able to defeat Grodd
if you want to read more about Grodd in
the comics some of his best storylines
are dog days that's the first time Grodd
meets the Wally West flash
he comes to Central City makes all the
pets and animals super smart and tries
to take over
but wall-e is able to defeat him with
the help of Pied Piper and vixen which
is kind of funny because Pied Piper is
gonna be on the TV show this week and
vixen is getting her own animated show
then there's gorilla city conquest
that's another attempt to kill sullivo
and take over gorilla city with the
intention of taking over the world
then there's the creation of a new
reverse-flash that story actually they
might weave that into season one of the
flash so if that ends up happening I'll
explain that story a little bit better
but Grodd is directly responsible for
the creation of the hunter zolomon
reverse-flash he engineered this massive
prison break from iron Heights and in
the process decides to torture Wally
West's friends and hunters olam on just
ends up being a casualty of that just
raise raise your hand wherever you're
sitting at your computer I know we all
can't see each other just raise your
hand if you think that they might try
that storyline another really awesome
story is rogue war he teamed up with the
rows to fight the flash mirror master
bust them out in the middle of a big
fight it's really awesome I know
everyone's really wondering if mirror
master is gonna be on the show then
during the black ring storyline you get
to see him go up against Lex Luthor and
he eats a ton of brains with this giant
spoon nice and gross nice and gross then
during flashpoint in the alternate
timeline created by the reverse-flash
broad successfully overthrew solovar to
take control at gorilla City and use
them to conquer Africa
you can totally read the new 52 stories
that they've done they're a little more
fantastical they involve gorillas
speedforce clerics and Grodd eating his
father's brains it's just a little
crazier so now let's just talk a little
bit about what the show might do with
the character just based on what we've
seen so far so let's look at our
checklist so we know that Harrison wells
is directly responsible for the creation
of garage Krim getting super smart and
keeping with season ones revenge theme
of you know STAR Labs people coming back
wanting to kill Harrison wells garage
could always return super-smart and
looking for revenge season wins a lot of
origin stories for all the characters so
really what I'd like to see if they're
gonna go full-on Grodd this year is at
the very end just get a teaser for
gorilla City like Grodd escapes and
starts to create gorilla city or maybe
even a teaser for solovar it's kind of
expensive to do CG for Apes so I'm not
expecting like a whole army of gorillas
anytime soon how
would that be though for the flash to go
visit gorilla City in season 2 I think
our biggest question right now is is
what is he gonna look like is it gonna
be CG is gonna be a combo is gonna look
like Rises the Planet of the Apes I mean
I can definitely say they don't have the
kind of money that Rise of the Planet of
the Apes has so it's probably gonna be a
mixture of what Andy Serkis looked like
with practical effects arrows kind of
taking the same approach with Ray
Palmer's atom suit marc guggenheim said
that on that show they wanted to
differentiate his suit from iron man's
and the Iron Man suit has all these CG
moving parts so they turned a lot of
those into practical elements I don't
have any idea what it's actually gonna
look like but we will probably get a
teaser for that in the next couple of
episodes really I'm just blown away that
they're doing Grodd so soon I never
expected this is probably the biggest
surprises of season 1 greg berlanti kind
of the you know the person behind all
these DC adaptations that Warner
Brothers said that he really had to
fight to keep that Easter egg in the
first episode he said that Warner
Brothers wanted to take it out but they
were like no leave it in it'll be really
fun for comic book fans cut to now where
it's become so successful that they said
yeah of course you could do Gorilla
Grodd bring him in do a big story it's
just a good example of how plans can
change based on success it's the same
situation with the firestorm character
and it kind of makes you wonder what
kind of craziness they're gonna try in
season 2 really I think what I'd like to
see them do is flash of two worlds
that's actually that's also a Carmine
Infantino story if you haven't read the
comics that's just like where the flash
stories get into a multiverse territory
so we haven't we haven't broached time
travel yet we'll do time travel then
we'll probably get into multiverse stuff
so here's my big question for you guys
you know how do you want to see the show
use Gorilla Grodd and do you want to see
him team up with the rogues at some
point
don't forget this week's episode is
actually gonna be the debut of Pied
Piper so whenever I post my review for
that I'll also explain his backstory
little he's one of the weirder flash
villains but I really like what the TV
show is done with him be sure to
subscribe to get that there's also been
a whole bunch of other news today too so
Fox just confirmed they're developing a
live-action x-men series no word on who
would star in it or which characters
they'd use I'm not really sure if I'm
gonna have time to make a video for it
so just feel free to talk about it in
the comments on this video we can all go
rewatch the animated series on Netflix
after Gotham tonight really big thank
you to everyone that's been submitting
fansubs for my videos you have no idea
how much itself it's been awesome you
guys are amazing
while you guys wait for Gotham to start
you can click here to catch up on the
show and you can click here for last
week's flash episode thank you so much
watching so big gorilla high-five I'll
see you guys tonight